ce qui est important avec les zazous
c'est qu'ils sont précurseurs de la
culture jeune en ce sens qu'ils tiennent
à se distinguer des adultes par le
costume par le style ainsi que par leur
passion exclusive pour cette musique
john key le jazz jazz
depuis quand les jeunes les écoute du
jazz depuis la fin des années 30 qu'ils
écoutent du jet les jeunes et perso pour
moi le jazz c'est plutôt sain mais non
le jazz c'est la musique des jeunes et
même des jeunes qui ont vraiment envie
de bouger
après guerre elle explose en voyant ces
images on dirait qu'un ces jeunes
dansent le rock mais non et danse le
jazz il dans ce big buck même pour être
précis